no cabe duda alguna que lo que le
ocurrió al abogado ordóñez fue un crimen
fue una brutal violación a los derechos
humanos cometida con alevosía por dos
agentes de la policía que ya lo tenían
bajo control y sin embargo se ensañaron
con él ahora este caso no es un caso
aislado hay múltiples denuncias que
nosotros hemos conocido y muy
recurrentes año tras año lo cual indica
que aquí la policía nacional debe ser
objeto de reformas de fondo reformas que
busquen mejorar la capacitación el
entrenamiento el manejo de armas letales
y armas obviamente no letales o menos
letales y sobre todo asegurarse que
cuente la policía con mecanismos
internos eficaces de control para
mantener la lo que es la disciplina
policial no ayuda que la policía siga
bajo las estructuras del ministerio
defensa habría que trasladarlo al
ministerio del interior y al mismo
tiempo
ayuda que cuando hay denuncias de esta
naturaleza son usualmente juzgadas por
la justicia penal militar como incluso
el caso del señor ordóñez donde se
garantiza muchas veces la impunidad de
los autores de estos delitos